Hi guys, I, uh-
I just wanted to say thank you guys so much for all of the love that you've shown since I posted that late night vlog
Uhm..
I- I woke up this morning, and I literally rolled over, opened my phone, and I just saw
like un- an ungodly number of notifications just with-
with understanding and love and sharing and- and it was
It was just a non-stop parade of support and- and I can't even describe to you
Like-
Like, how good that was for me at the moment.
'Cause I didn't know the response that video was going to get, I really didn't
I was just putting my feelings out there
because I couldn't keep bottling them up like that
and I- I didn't know if it was going to come across as like whining like "Boohoo. Oh, I have so much success-
it's- it's such a pain to have all these opportunities laid out before me." Like
I didn't want it to come across that way and I
I- I- I I'm really happy
That-
that people understood that and-
and thank you.
Thank you for that.
I- I've spent all morning reading messages and reading comments and reading everything that you guys have put out there
There's new pieces of fan art that are being made in support of it
And- and I just wanted to say like
before I before I like move on to other silly Let's Plays that I have planned for today,
Which I do have a lot, and there's a really silly video in the pipeline.
But I didn't wanna- I didn't wanna to bowl over all of those- like- all those really important emotions that came out
overnight an- and if you haven't seen the video yet get ready for "Big Blubbering Baby Markiplier" because
That's uh- That's what I'm doing.
Uhm..
But I- I just- I had to stop, and thank you guys. I had to before I moved on to anything else.
I had to.
And I don't want you guys to worry
I'll try to keep this short and sweet because I've said enough of what I said
But I- I don't want you guys to worry about
me,
and how I'm doing and where I'm going because #1 : I'm not quitting YouTube.
Like, I- I've been doing this for five years and that may seem like a long time, but that's actually not a long time.
That's-that's like undergrad.
You know that- that's enough to get a college degree.
uhhh- and- and,
Once you get that college degree and once you've learned and spent all that time,
doing the theory of it when you step out of those doors into the real world,
Uh...
You find out you don't know nearly as much as you thought you did, but that's not what worries me.
I- I don't want people to think that I'm afraid of taking the next step in going, like, even farther
than I- I'm- like
than I am now because
Like that doesn't scare me.
Like, knowing the future has different opportunities and challenges that doesn't scare me at all.
That excite me, *laughs* that excites me.
I just can't wait to go out there and find out what I'm good at and what I'm bad at like
I just can't wait to fail. Like I just can't wait to fall flat on my face. I just can't wait to,
like see how far I go, and then immediately fall down and then get back up and just prove people wrong.
Like God, I love that!
I love failing because it just gives me an idea of how much farther I need to go and it gives me an idea of
of what the road is leading to.
And that is what I love like, I love that. I love
seeing those challenges. I love meeting them. I love showing people what I can do
Because I mean that's what it's all been about when I say that at the beginning of my YouTube channel
I was only looking up. It's because I could only look up.
I was at rock bottom.
There was no down, and if there was a down I didn't want to see it.
So the only way to go forward was just to keep doing it every day.
Because, every day was better than the last day.
Because every day,
new people were coming in and seeing my stuff and I get to meet them and show them who I was an- and at the
same time,
discover,
who I am.
Like, I didn't know who I was back then, I don't fully understand myself now.
Like I don't- and that again, that doesn't scare me.
Like, I know I'm discovering new things about myself every day, and I'm and I'm growing as a person and I'm learning new things.
And as you guys are watching me, you're growing, too.
And you are learning and what I say does influence you and what you say does influence me.
Like the beautiful thing about Youtube is that it's a two-way street,
like, I learn from you, and you learn from me. And then in that circle,
that we discover who we really are.
And that's a never ending journey.
Like beyond the five years that I've been doing youtube and into the five years that I'll keep doing youTube and do other big
projects. Like I'll still be figuring out
who I am.
And I really hope that doesn't scare anybody.
Because I don't know what I want to do like,
I don't know what I want to dedicate my time to fully and I know that I can't dedicate my time to everything.
I know that, and I accept that, and I understand.
But I think that going into the future
So long as I understand is that each day, can be better than the last day.
And so long as I can keep moving forward.
That makes it all worth it.
That makes it one big beautiful journey.
And the end of the road isn't important,
where I end up isn't important because I'm never gonna stop moving.
Not until the day I die. I'm not gonna stop moving.
and I think that's a beautiful thing.
and it's even more beautiful that
like, I can be honest with you guys about my fears and apprehensions.
And I can be open with you about that, and you can be open with me about that too. Like...
That's just amazing.
So anyway, I said I'd keep this short and sweet still got blabbery, but it's okay. *Chuckles*
'Cause I'm not gonna stop!
I'm not, going to stop being blabbery. I'm not- I'm gonna keep doing it, so,
Just thank you guys.
Thank you for being here with me on this crazy journey. Thank you for trusting me
in knowing where I'm going which-
Psst! I don't! but that's okay because I'm always going to keep trying to
steer all of us in the right direction.
So thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you for all the love. Share that love with everybody you see today.
Spread it around.. and uh..
Oh! and let's do a charity livestream tomorrow.
How about that?
That'll be pretty cool.
about 10 AM, sound good? Pacific Time.
Yeah, we'll do that.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
The silliness will return! And normal Let's Plays will continue as per scheduled. Uhh
And, as always, I will see you,
in the next video!
Buh-bye! ♥